today I'll stick to football we're doing
a little stock watch because it is big
board season we're also gonna fix the
Cleveland Browns yes it is that time of
year we're gonna answer your draft draft
questions but Connor it does feel like a
holiday it's like up right between
Halloween and Thanksgiving and it's a
little later this year than normal the
two and six Browns we're gonna address
them today fix them I don't know if we
can draft a head coach but we're
definitely gonna talk about it
yeah the Browns the Raiders they're
usually the team's we start with when we
do the fixing segment each year but this
year we kind of put a curveball on it
and we we started with the Bengals who
have earned it the Jets they certainly
earned it as well you know obviously the
Dolphins we're gonna get there but we're
not in a rush here at stick to football
they just want this yeah this was kind
of an SOS in a way because Browns fans
have actually been asking hey what do we
got to do to turn this thing around
because it has not gone the way we
thought and we've always enjoyed our
relationship with the Browns fans on
this show because when this show started
they were in the middle of one of the
biggest rebuilds we've seen in NFL
history you know now they feel the
roster has taken you know turn the
corner but the coaching staff is not so
we'll go through all that today I just
want to hug all our Browns fans because
it's like that the expectations this
summer and I was on board I was jumping
up there saying they were gonna win the
AFC North the expectations from summer
to now it's it has to be depressing and
I'm not poking fun at Cleveland fans
like it has to just be completely
gut-wrenching to be like oh my god we've
turned the corner and now it's like why
can't we have nice things like what did
what did we do to deserve this so we're
gonna try to help our Browns fans out
today but first we got a lot of college
football news actually
Florida State fires really Taggart we
talked about this on the Monday show
they pay an astronomical sum to get out
of his contract a one-year guy at Oregon
goes to Florida State doesn't work out
there surprise surprise they have hired
a firm that's gonna come in and help
with the search they got boosters
involved but I was interested in this
because and we're recording this Tuesday
morning so if news breaks after this I
apologize but the statement that came
out Monday Florida State said we want to
name a new head coach by the end of the
season and people who don't follow
college football religiously it's like
you're here for the draft and NFL talk
you might not know this
but in college football it is just like
a written agreement that you're not
going to announce in season that a coach
is leaving a college you just don't you
don't do it it's it's almost unheard of
so when I've read that Monday it's like
okay they're going after someone who's
not currently working the best coach not
currently working as Urban Meyer he's
not going to Florida State the next best
name on the list and I think this is a
curveball is Bob Stoops now we talked
about Monday maybe Mark Stoops his name
had been making for this job but if they
can get Bob Stoops that's enormous for
Florida State it is it's a great game
especially for a guy that we thought
probably wanted to take a little time
away from college football and he has
and that itch comes back really quick he
actually is the head coach and general
manager of an XFL team in right Alice
the Renegades now I don't think that's
gonna deter him from taking a
high-profile job like Florida State now
something we talked about on the Monday
show a lot Matt is that Florida State
has a lot of money and that's because
the Boosters at Florida State are
willing to give up a lot of money and
that's a big whether you think Florida
State has lost its luster or not and if
actually they have lost some this is
still a program with some historic roots
so your golden golden era days and the
money to lure a guy back in that they
feel concern things around now I
actually do think Stoops can get a lot
of guys to come play for him and in a
creative way that Florida State probably
hasn't seen overall too much recently
especially some of the guys they've had
their Willie Taggart being one in terms
of recruiting I think Stoops would be a
big-time upgrade and he'd be in it for
the long haul so I like it I'm a little
surprised by it because I didn't know
how quickly he'd be interested in this
job but it sounds like the interest this
is pretty significant right now it does
and this is a guy who has a little bit
of experience in Florida I mean he went
to Iowa he's from Ohio so you're like
this a Rust Belt guy but he coached at
florid he was the assistant head coach
and defensive coordinator from 1996 to
1998 under Steve Spurrier so he has some
experience in the state of Florida which
i think is important to just kind of
understand how the groundwork is laid
there in that state
for recruiting and working with the high
school coaches but also Bob Stoops is a
name that really just recruits itself
you know there are a couple of guys like
what Pete Carroll went to USC USC was
down be like okay he that name really
recruits itself and I feel like Bob
Stoops is one of those names where his
reputation you know big game Bob and
what he did at Oklahoma his you know
what 16 17 years there was really
unprecedented and he turned that program
around so I think if Florida State can
lure Bob Stoops away from the XFL which
probably won't be that hard to do then I
think that this is a great hire for
missus slam dunk - Florida State who I
really thought they were gonna mess this
up and go after you know a mid-major guy
who hadn't really proven himself and
would be more of a risk than this but
Bob Stoops is that's about as big of a
homerun as you can expect to get if
you're Florida State it absolutely is I
mean this is a coach with almost an 800
winning percentage here Matt and a guy
that consistently for a long time was
winning 11 or 12 or you know ten games
year after year and you go into the ACC
which is not an impressive conference
right now even their top dog clemson has
looked vulnerable at times this year but
take away clemson and you look at the
rest of the teams in that conference
we've seen Louisville finally go in the
right direction we thought Miami was
gonna go in the right direction this
year they really haven't been what we
expected and the rest is a lot of teams
that are trying to turn things around so
I think of your FSU and you want to go
for the whole package not the hey we're
like pj fleck for instance pj fleck
would have been a guy that you hire in
about three years you would have known
if it was the right choice it needed
that much time Bob Stoops you're
probably gonna know if it was the right
choice within a year or two and it
probably will work out that's what's
exciting about this is that FSU fans and
we know them very well they want instant
returns and this is the guy that can get
you them it absolutely is
and another college who's going back to
a familiar name is Rutgers where Greg
Schiano up there's reports that there
may be close to a reunion happening
shadow is the head coach there for 10
years before he took the head coaching
job at with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers but
this is like this is such good news for
Bill Belichick in the New England
Patriots because they draft so many
Rutgers players that Greg Shadow is just
going to become like the minor league
for
Patriot's he's still relatively young 53
years old for a guy who's been coaching
for a really really long time I like
Gregg shadow I actually thought
Tennessee should have hired him as head
coach obviously some people in the media
made sure that that didn't happen with
some allegations that proved to be
unfounded but gray shadow I think it's a
really really good coach and he's good
for a place like Rutgers where there
aren't a ton of expectations he can
recruit those Jersey and Pennsylvania
kids who are incredibly tough and are
gonna play his style of football and
there's not an expectation that he's
gonna turn Rutgers around and make it
you know a perennial powerhouse but
they're gonna be a very competitive team
with him and said coach yeah they are
he's a Jersey guy this was always you
know really kind of the best spot for
him in terms of where he's been
successful and I think when you look at
Rutgers right now Matt it's hard to
figure out who would take this job
because it's been a buzz saw for a long
time where you go there and and you
simply are just getting out recruited
out coached
out performed it's a big problem across
the board and Shanna was there for I
mean 10 years and had a winning record
at Rutgers how many guys can say that in
this era it's it's not easy to do and
when he took over the program they were
a 2 and a 1 win team so he really turned
them around where they were going from
hey they might win one or two maybe four
games in a good year so this team should
win eight games every year now the
question is does he have enough left in
the tank to do this again because of how
poorly Rutgers has you know taken a
spiral since he left and it's a fair
question but I do think he has the right
roots in New Jersey where it really
matters because there's a lot of good
football in New Jersey where he could
steal some of those kids get them to
come play for Rutgers and maybe not be
in the basement of their conference year
after year I know a lot of people at
Ohio State I mean Larry Johnson there's
the best defensive line coach in the
country but a lot of people - a high of
state will look at at what he did for
his two years there and how good that
secondary was I mean think of all the
Ohio State guys in the NFL right now
from the secondary which that is Greg
Shaw knows I think specialty even though
um you don't really we don't talk enough
about how good here's the secondary
coach but I know a lot of folks really
really believe that that he had a hand
in developing some of those guys so Shaw
knows ability to develop to recruit it's
gonna be a tough
Rutger so two hires that we hope happen
because both would be great for those
colleges also great for us as far as NFL
draft prospects go one thing to talk
about on the NFL side of it and you and
I just came back from London it's an
amazing city I loved the people there
they love NFL football as they call it
the the Chargers the Oakland the NFL and
apparently the Los Angeles chargers are
talking about maybe getting together to
go to London now it's obvious the
Chargers aren't working in LA they're
playing in a soccer stadium that holds
like 20,000 people every week there are
more fans of the away team like that
when the Steelers played there it
sounded like a Steelers home game it is
a mess I don't know that London is the
answer though like that's a ten and a
half hour direct flight from LA to
London
I don't know how Philip Rivers who is a
free agent after this year like he
already rides in like a special van so
that he can live in San Diego and play
in LA if they're gonna go to London
they're drafting a quarterback in the
first round because there's no way in
hell Phil forevers that's gonna go to
London for half the year no shot and the
problem is Matt it and it doesn't end
there there's a lot of guys I love the
City of London I love the London fans
and the London fans will be the first to
tell you that because I asked this to
millions of people I said if a team ever
comes here do you pivot from the team
you root for - what will be your local
team and they go no they go I root for
the Browns I root for the Jays right IRA
I mean we saw every single fan their
bills Giants liens on and on and on
where they're not just gonna walk away
so I do think the City of London will
rally around and support a team and even
the fans that aren't necessarily rooting
for that team specifically will go to
the games which is very special and I
think London football in London for
eight games a year is really exciting
but let's address the elephant in the
room Matt and we've talked about this
with a lot of people around the NFL
because the NFL has really wanted this
to happen
they expect it to happen in the next
couple of years I don't know if that's a
pipe dream but there's a lot of hurdles
that come with this you have to pay
those players differently you have to
the expectations differently for those
players for their lives are their
families going to go live in London or
are those players going to just live out
in London for the season and then come
home and train and they get to come home
once a year for the bye week and besides
the fact they make a lot of trips
overseas to play their away games
there's a lot of logistics here that
aren't easy and you talk the teams you
talk to coaches I know plenty that have
gone and made that trip for games and
even Scouts and they say listen it's a
it's a big blow to our rhythm our
momentum everything changes when we go
out there they're like we love the trip
but at the end of the day it's very
tough for a football team so now imagine
this being a team's life essentially
during the season I think there'll be a
lot of push back here but in terms of
the franchise for how bad things are
going for the Chargers right now not on
the field but off the field this might
be the best solution it really might be
because otherwise I mean do you go back
to San Diego well I don't have a better
one that's what I'd like to say I don't
either
I really don't there's just not many
cities set up Oakland I can't support
the Raiders so they're not gonna take
the Chargers and I guess you could go
back to San Diego and be like hey maybe
this wasn't as bad as we thought but it
is just it's a messy situation as
someone who has spent a lot of time in
San Francisco it kills me that there's
not a team in San Francisco so I wonder
if like but there's nowhere to play so
you're running into the same problem of
where you gonna play for three years
Stanford like wait what are you gonna do
share stadium with the Niners San Jose
could support a team it's big enough but
there's nowhere to play so I think the
Chargers like they're almost homeless at
this point which does make you wonder if
the league would say okay the only
market that we don't have a team in that
we want a team in is London we're gonna
have to send you guys over there my
problem as someone who is like a little
OCD this would kill the divisions though
somewhat there would have to be
realignment because the Chargers if
they're in London they can't be in the
AFC West are they dependent like right
like Notre Dame like what so it's like
you almost have to take someone from the
east and put them in the north or south
and then someone from the north or south
has to go to the west it's a nightmare
know what I mean North could go to the
West those are all Rust Belt teams you
almost have to this is crazy but you'd
really realistically have to look at
putting the dolphins elsewhere and
making the London team in the AFC East
that's what you would come down to you
because the Jets the bills and the
Patriots have the most reasonable trip
over there in terms of collective
division guys right now the problem with
the NFC East because of course you're
sitting there saying oh the Giants the
Redskins and Eagles are easy to do it to
I guess you can move Dallas you think
Jerry Jones is gonna move the Cowboys
out of the NFC East
I don't like there are the logistical
issues and I'm happy I got in charge
right now there's issues across the
board not even just like how do you fly
teams over there eight weeks out of the
year then how do you fly them back over
here eight weeks out of the year it is
an absolute mess dude absolutely yes but
it is the NFL wants this I love the end
of those aspirations because a lot of
the international fans not just London
but also in Germany there are fans
around the world I mean we get listeners
from Brazil Mexico all these places that
they crave and want football but I think
at the same time too
while them revenue is nice more fans as
nice more people loving the game is
great you do have to at some point
consider what's right for the players
Tuesday morning my new big board came
out top 32 players overall in the top 10
players at each position as you would
expect Twitter is on fire people want to
know where their favorite player is why
I hate their favorite team so Connor
we're just gonna kind of run through
some maybe surprises that that I've seen
on Twitter and and have a little bit of
a nuanced discussion because that can be
hard to do in an article it could be a
lot easier to do over a podcast yeah it
is and the first one on the list that
you have is to stock down and I'm
curious about this one and I need a lot
of summer hype so I think that plays
into it but is Andrew Thomas a lot of
people a lot of fans believe he could be
a franchise tackle a franchise offensive
lineman he's been DeAndre Swift's guy up
front for Georgia
what's the latest for him Matt yeah you
know watching him over the last couple
of weeks and being able to really hone
in and study his game I'm not in love
with his movement ability I think his
power is amazing
he has heavy hands he does have good arm
length I don't think if he is
six-five as he's listed I'll be
surprised I don't know if you've if
you've noticed he kind of has a weird
body yes it's very nice
we're frame he's not built like Tyrone
Smith or Tripp Williams he's not built
like Ronnie Stanley and look he's more
compact right very so when you look at
him you're like it's almost hard to
believe like okay is he really 65 320 or
is he 6-4 335 because he looks you know
bigger then he's listed at so I wonder
about that and again just the movement
skills I haven't been in love with and I
think with what offensive tackles have
to do in the NFL now you have to be able
to move you have to be able to slide a
mirror you'd be able to recover back to
the inside with speed no doubt he has
power and there might be schemes where
he can be a really good left tackle
but I just can't rank him in the top 10
and say this is a franchise left tackle
when I don't see that movement ability
from him I really like Andrew Thomas but
I think a lot of people were shocked
when we did the mock draft Monday and I
had the jets taking Jerry Judy instead
of him and what it comes down to me is
Jerry Judy's gonna greet out as a much
much better player because Jerry judy
has the chance to be special I know
you've compared them to Odell Beckham in
the past I think the guy is truly a
number one wide receiver Sam Donald has
never had that and this is probably the
opportunity to go get that I understand
the argument the Jets need to solve
corner edge tackle a lot of teams do and
that's why Andrew Thomas will probably
still be a high pick but at the end of
the day I think I'm I'm in this no-man's
land of I really like Andrew Thomas I
think he's a phenomenal run blocker he'd
probably be an elite guard and I hate
saying that take a tackle and term to
guard I think he could be a good tackle
I'm not convinced yet that he's this
elite tackle where you're gonna use a
top three pick on him and that's what
we're trying to figure out right now
yeah and I believe I said this on one of
our shows last week that he reminds me
of Lyle Collins lay and that's a good
player there's a good player but are you
not a left tackle so it might not be a
top three pick that sort of goes down to
you know what I mean absolutely not
so many teams need offensive line and
I've said this before you really this is
the year you want to get creative and
free agency and the trade market and
then going to the draft and see how the
board Falls because I like a lot of
players that are going to be late
available and later around one or the
second round it tackled as well where
you might strike some better value we'll
see but on a happier note you have CJ
Henderson as a stock up guy this year
after a slow start for him he's going
back up I thought he did start slowly
this year and I'm not just talking like
passes defensed and interceptions I
really thought he just his play was a
little bit off it seems like he has they
re sparked the fire in himself a little
bit he's been playing much more
aggressively
I know Florida has lost a couple games
now to LSU into Georgia but I think CJ
Henderson is a really good man coverage
corner and there just aren't enough of
those you know it's a supply and demand
is not great but when it comes down to
it like when I'm stacking a big board is
that you're betting on these players
you're putting your name on that player
that you're stamp on the player and
they're you know how many guys in this
class do you really feel like okay he's
gonna be a good player I'm willing to
put my name on that guy so CJ Henderson
the more I started shuffling the board
and moving guys down it's like okay who
do I really believe in not Who am I told
is good not who other guys in the media
about like but who do I like as a player
regardless of Scouts and everyone else
and I like CJ Henderson he's aggressive
he's physical I know that he tackling is
like okay maybe sometimes he does it
sometimes he doesn't
I really think that he's just trying not
to get hurt before he jumps to the NFL
but a 6-1 185 pound corner who is not
afraid to play physically through
coverage and to come up and play in the
run that's the kind of guy that I want
every time I'm very conflicted on CJ
Henderson because you look at the player
you look at the physical profile the
athlete the size the length and it's
everything you want in a corner and I'm
I stand with you that I don't think he's
been very fiery this year on the field I
think I've seen kind of a complacent
attitude and we saw that with greedy
Williams at times his last year at LSU
where you want them just a little bit
more from them it's almost like you look
at Henderson and you're like well he
could be as good as Jeff Okuda but he's
just not a CUDA plays with a different
edge and I think it's gonna be
interesting to really watch him this
year because is it a question of hey
just doesn't have his foot on the gas
right now because he doesn't want to get
hurt because you know the raw physical
talent is there yep and I will say we've
talked a lot about oh is Florida DBU
Florida guys have not done that well in
the NFL so that in again you've got the
player not the helmet but that is
something that you have to be aware of
no it's it's crazy when you look at
Vernon Hargreaves the the year that you
will Quincey Wilson and Jen tease Taber
yep both went pretty early I mean the
only two Marcus Mays been good when
healthy he's been banged up and Brian
Poole wasn't even drafted and he's been
a good slot corner but the Florida the
high-profile Florida DBS have not panned
out at all yeah and another guy that it
pains me to move him down because I felt
like I not that I was the first person
to discover this player but I feel like
I was early on him last year AJ up in SA
Iowa who was so good last year as a
backup you had ten and a half sacks he
had a ton of tackles for loss this year
he's been very very quiet three and a
half sacks and I know we've talked about
it before on the show it feels like
everyone they play is keying on him and
trying to slow him down but he doesn't
look to have as much spark in his first
step this year so I like a JEP Anessa a
lot I still have him ranked fairly
highly I still haven't number 12 overall
but I had to die to move my guy down
because it's six foot six to 80 like
you're gonna have to do a lot of things
to get free you're gonna have to have
speed you have to power and ability to
mix and match those things I'm just not
seeing that from him this year so only
three and a half sacks so far in eight
games I know I've said before I think
what's testing gets here he'll have a
chance to rise back up the board but
this is not a top three or top five guy
in this class I think the frustrating
thing is you talk gross meadows has just
been a better player this year than him
and I don't think a lot of people
expected that coming into the year with
epinet Stalin and going from a backup
last year to a full-time player he
really he played enough snaps here he
had double-digit sacks but you just like
to see a little bit more out of
epinephelus a lot more but he's had some
monster games this year and we hope to
see him at the Senior Bowl Michael
Pittman jr. stock up what is the latest
you've seen from him Matt oh my god
watching the Oregon game I'm so
disappointed because I picked you I see
to win but watching Michael Pittman and
they have other targets I mean what they
have it was Vaughn's what that was Saint
Brown like good young receivers but
Pittman
strength in his hands is exceptionally
his grip strength his ability to just
hold on to the ball and there were some
errant throws from slovis his ability to
just pull in the tough catching in his
frame six foot four to 20 he's very very
well-built I don't know that he's the
fastest guy in the world but he does
look quicker this year 58 catches
already eight touchdowns not a first
rounder for me but if I can get Michael
Pittman jr. in like the middle around 2
I actually think that he could develop
into a starting X wide receiver you're
not gonna put a dude like this in the
slot but a team like you know Buffalo if
they can't get a receiver in the first
round Pittman is exactly what they need
in the second round or we've talked
about like if Carolina wants to add some
size to go with DJ Morton Curtis Samuel
he's gonna be a really good fit for
teams like that where they want a
physical outside receiver who can post
up but I've also been seeing him win
over the middle of the field because his
hands are just so so strong I can't
figure this guy out for the life of me
and that's why I'm just praying he goes
to the Senior Bowl so we can get down on
that field should I mean he'll be
excited and I'll tell you what I'll tell
you why Matt when we saw him against
Utah we're like oh he's faster than we
thought and you see him against Oregon
and Colorado and he's big he's strong
he's got good hands when I went to see
him against Washington besides one
touchdown that was almost a missed
assignment from Washington he couldn't
get off the line of scrimmage he
couldn't run by anyone those Washington
defensive backs they get their hands on
you and they really they bump and run
and he struggled and you sit there and
you go well those are the kind of DBS
he's gonna see in the NFL and will that
work at the next level so I've seen it
from Pittman where nobody can cover him
and I've seen it from him where he can't
get off the line of scrimmage I don't
know what he is and I think that's okay
at this point of the process because
he's somebody where we're probably gonna
get to see him down in Mobile in person
we're probably gonna catch up on tape
and it'll paint a whole picture and to
be honest with you he's probably
something right in the middle he might
be a pretty good possession guy with a
big body that can be your number three
as you're sealing your number to target
and that's okay yeah exactly and I I
think watching the organ like they were
rolling coverage his way and it opened
up everything for Vaughn's and Saint
Brown buttons yeah we do need to see him
make someplace another guy moving up and
this is the most improved player outside
jobber oh that I've seen this year and
that's JK Dobbins ed Ohio State
he looks faster he looks more physical
his vision looks better and this is a
fairly young Ohio State offensive line
so it's not like he just got you know
has five seniors in front of him and
he's rolling behind it there's a young
offensive line but already this year he
has 1100 rushing yards and nine
touchdowns he's catching the ball 13
catches for two touchdowns JK Dobbins
just continues every week to move up for
me to the point where and I feel like
with running backs this year I'm gonna
try to do a much better job of saying
okay for this offense this dude's a
really good fit for some teams I think
JK Dobbins would be a better back than
Travis Eaton because he has that inside
run ability
we've seen some breakaway speed from him
so I am just after last year I was like
man what happened to this guy who was so
good as a freshman but he's changed his
body I mean he has slimmed down so much
and it shows he's faster he's more
explosive and I think that's allowed him
to be much better at the second third
level as a running back during his
freshman season we watched a guy I'm ago
that is prime Doug Martin like when Doug
Martin was a fourteen hundred yard
player he could run to the outside with
speed he can catch he could do
everything sophomore year no idea who
that was this year he's back again I
love what we've seen from JK Dobbins
this is a fun running back class because
you can go and find yourself a starter
and what kind of flavor you like for
your scheme pretty much in the first
three rounds I feel like we've done
we've gone over with DeAndre swift
Jonathan Taylor Najee Harris plenty of
times
obviously eaten but Dobbins is right in
the mix here where he just seems
reliable that's what I really like about
Dobbins he doesn't have these flat games
he's only had two games this year where
he didn't go over a hundred yards and
one of those games you only got eight
carries because right they absolutely
smoked Miami Ohio he's averaging over
seven yards of carry I think he does
make the most of the few targets he gets
in the pass game so JK Dobbins has done
himself a lot of favors this year he
really really has I'm such a big fan of
his now let's talk a little bit about
quarterbacks because I know a lot of
people listening that's all they care
about right now is the quarterbacks
what's gonna happen and I actually wrote
as part of this big board article I'm
disappointed by the quarterbacks and I
think that like if there was a key word
a takeaway it would be consistency too
has been incredibly consistent when not
hurt Joe burrow has been incredibly
consistent this year Jake from has been
incredibly consistent where I struggle
with guys like Justin Herbert Jacob
Eason Jordan love Jordan loves a big one
Jalen hurts even if we're gonna consider
him part of the quarterback class at
least the top tier of it I'm very
disappointed by the inconsistency Jacob
Eason not good against any good defenses
a Justin Herbert the numbers look good
but to play like if the actual watching
him play I think he's still missing too
often and I will applaud him for coming
back he took a hard hit to the knee went
to the 10th came back in that USC game
for a guy who we've talked about maybe
isn't the mentally toughest guy that
showed me a lot it really did but I've
just been very down on Eason love-love
has traits for days you know I'll tell
you this now a lot of people didn't like
it when we said Josh Allen was gonna be
a top-10 pick but he was and it was
based on traits Jordan love could also
be a top-10 pick because of those same
traits and in the fact that he doesn't
have great talent around him I think
almost helps his draft stock because
when he plays poorly you can say oh well
he has [ __ ] around him so of course he's
gonna play poorly and he plays well he's
oh my god he's elevating the talent
around him but I think a quarterback
class where we've said there might be
four five guys drafted in the first
round a lot of these dudes need to step
up they really do I the only two I will
even come we'll have a first round great
on and I'm not official with this is to
Anjali the other guys it's very hard to
make that case Eason and Herbert are
funny because they have the Josh Allen
type of thing and even Rosen was like
this too when they do it right it looks
so pretty it's a beautiful beautiful
ball they throw they got they could
change speeds on the ball everything
just looks perfect but you have to
almost dig at times for those samples
for the next level
Jordan love what scares me as and here
this one out Matt against Wake Forest
LSU and BYU he's thrown three
interceptions in each of those games
that's nine interceptions against
against three pretty decent teams
obviously LSU is great Wake Forest's and
BYU the rest of the teams he plays I
mean those what
stats mean to you at this point and you
go and you watch all the games for the
traits but I think at the end of the day
he's not even close to being NFL ready I
mean not even close this is like a draft
in the second or third round developed
the traits for a year or two and I was
told that story with Christian
Hackenberg once upon a time Jordan love
is not Christian Hackenberg but the
point stands if you need to put a guy in
ice for a very long time there's a
pretty good chance that investments not
gonna pay off in the NFL and not
everyone's Pat mahomes forever wants to
throw that one back in my face
I was waiting to say it I was born
Rogers I was like you were those in the
yeah there's one each of those in the
world so and that happened like 15 years
apart exactly and I'm not saying Jordan
love won't be great but the problem is
he's just not even close right now where
you have to consider going back to
school if you're Jordan love so I'm with
you a whole other side of that the the
argument that I think that he'll hear
from agents and will get from teams is
the town around goes bad so I go back
and it was Josh down at Wyoming - it's
like how well that team is not getting
better so might as well come out and get
your money like you're not thinking
about what's best for the guy's career
long term you're thinking about well
you're gonna be a top ten pick he's
probably come out so I didn't orden
Love's gonna be a fascinating one to
study
once we know if he's in or out and I'll
say the same thing with Jake from I love
watching Jake fry and play college
football I absolutely love it but he's
so limited physically but I've seen guys
like that dominate Eli Manning was that
way I think Drew Brees to some extent is
that way maybe he'll even if his floors
Andy Dalton and II don't have a couple
good years and then just got kind of
surrounded by a team that was falling
apart so Jake from is really interesting
for me too and we're gonna talk a lot
about these quarterbacks over the next
couple months because this this class so
many teams need the quarterbacks and
we're not sold on most of them outside
of the top - all right let's take a
break we come back we're going to fix
the Cleveland Browns step number one
Baker you gotta shave that mustache Oh
Cleveland Browns fans we feel for you
guys we've been there Conners a Jets fan
I'm a Niners fan
we've absolutely been there we know how
this goes and we are sorry but we're
here to help by fixing the Browns it's a
team that has 60 million dollars in
expected cap space they have ten
draft picks four of those in the first
three rounds they don't have a lot of
free agents of their own to try to keep
and I've said earlier this summer when I
had to start looking at the 2020 draft
be like gosh
the Browns don't have a lot of needs on
paper and I still maintain that this is
not a team outside of the offensive
tackle
left tackle specifically that you would
say has a lot of needs on paper which is
why if we're fixing the Cleveland Browns
the first step he's firing Freddie
kitchens and bringing in a head coach
who can develop and get the talent that
this team has playing well elevate the
talent that you have on the roster
Freddie kitchens is not doing that we're
seeing it with issues like Jermaine
whitehead with obj and Jarvis Landry
wearing unapproved cleats
could you imagine that happening in New
England no absolutely no could you
imagine that happening in San Francisco
no there's no way they need someone who
can hold this roster accountable and who
can coach the talent the John Dorsey and
that amazing front office staff that
we've applauded for years can get there
they're putting good players together
now they need a coach who can do that
the biggest question is who is that guy
is it I mean who is it
I can't rally behind that one I can't
either when he's a good coach but god I
would like I'm falling asleep at that
idea yeah I just think that at the end
of that Green Bay tenure McCarthy had
really he checked out
he really checked out and I know
anything would have been better than
Adam GaSe but I heard he didn't even
really interview very well with the Jets
where it was like man you know does he
does he still have it does he still want
it and maybe a year away was good for
him and you know there's the connection
there
for Cleveland and I do think it would
bring accountability to this very
talented roster I just don't know if I
could be excited about it is my point
Matt I can't be and I know a lot of
Cleveland fans what are gonna want us to
talk about one name in particular I Lee
Lincoln Riley hey Lincoln Riley can
reunite with Baker Mayfield he can have
a great running back in Nick Chubb he
have two amazing receivers in Odell
Beckham jr. and Jarvis Landry why not if
there's gonna be a job that he's gonna
take why wouldn't this be it
I and this is all instinct for me it's
all gut for me
I don't think Lincoln Riley's gonna
leave one of the best jobs in college
football at the University of Oklahoma
to take a job where he's gonna have to
how to build a team and yes he and Baker
made beautiful beautiful music together
we also don't know if that song will
play in the NFL so I think with Lincoln
Riley yes he's a hell of a coach and
he's three maybe three Heisman winners
in a row we'll see what happens of Jalen
hurts down the stretch here but man I I
just don't know that Cleveland can
entice a Lincoln Riley to come work
under John Dorsey and to have all the
pressure of turning around a fanbase
that is just you know dang near
depressed level right now well I think
what you have to ask yourself is if
you're Lincoln Riley not the Browns
because I've fallen into this pipe dream
as well I wanted Matt Campbell to go to
the Jets
he said he'll know you have to ask
yourself why would Lincoln Riley go to
the Browns he's winning at Oklahoma he
makes a lot of money at Oklahoma as more
teams come calling to try to steal him
he's gonna make more money at Oklahoma
and also this is something we've heard
forever Matt and maybe this changes
we've been told all along the only job
Lincoln Riley will go to the NFL for is
the Dallas Cowboys and if that's true
that cancels this out right away exactly
it doesn't matter
and also there's there's a different
expectation level when you're a lot of
people go this is a weird thing that
I've noticed is like it's just not true
it's false I'll be like oh well it's
Cleveland the media stuff and Cleveland
man yes they're tough yes it is it's not
New York but it's hard green not no it's
it's not some kind of you know stroll
down the easy lane it's you know what I
mean it's it's a tough job to walk into
where does Lincoln need that kind of
stress now I don't this is fixing the
brown so I don't want to be why why
these are all the wrong things for the
Browns but I think we have to get a
little more realistic in case the
Lincoln Riley dream does not
happen and here's what I was gonna go
with that and I'm glad you you pivoted
perfectly you mentioned that you wanted
this guy to be a head coach of the Jets
last year and he said no that's Matt
Campbell who guess what is from Ohio
which I think all good coaches are but a
guy who is not from exactly from
Cleveland he's from very close to
Cleveland and could be a guy that could
come in and you what you hear about Matt
Campbell is he's not gonna kill you with
axes nose but he's so good at culture
guess what Cleveland needs right now
culture they need a leadership they need
a CEO and I think that's what Maddie
Campbell brings to this is someone who
he gets that area he and John Dorsey are
cut from the same cloth I think they
would work very very well together
he might need help filling out a staff I
think that's one of the keys if I'm Matt
Campbell I'm gonna apologize to Todd
Monken and say hey I know the last coach
did you wrong would you please stay on
and actually be my offensive coordinator
would you actually work with Baker
Mayfield
would you help design this offense and
call the place instead of basically just
being a glorified quarterbacks coach so
Matt Campbell yeah he might need a
little bit of help but I am a big
believer in his talents as a head coach
as his CEO I actually think he's better
suited for the NFL deenis College
because you know he's not great at the
locker room adjustments but what he is
good at is instituting a culture and
it's executing it and seeing it through
so that to me is better for the NFL in
college I think Maddie Campbell this is
such an obvious fit if they want to go
to someone who's not Mike McCarthy I'm
with you all the way on that Matt
Campbell is the Midwest version of like
the Matt rule style of coaching and Matt
rule is at Baylor right now but Matt
rule is a northeast kind of guy he's
from New York he coach for the Giants he
rebuilt temple I do think if the Jets
are Giants job opens up he'll be in that
conversation for the Jets will be the
second year in a row Matt Campbell is
the guy where he doesn't want New York
he that's not where he wants to be he
likes the Midwest I was always told that
he wanted the Ohio State job guess who's
not going anywhere anytime soon that guy
Ryan day is pretty good and that makes
you wonder what is next for Matt
Campbell I I mean there was talk that he
was one of the favorites when the FSU
job too opened up that doesn't look like
it's happening who knows if he even
wants that kind of job right
I think the Browns job is honestly
perfect for him if he's ready for the
what's next after Iowa State for all the
reasons you said Matt and you brought up
a name that we have to talk about not
just as the offensive coordinator
because there's a chance he'll be the
interim head coach now I don't think the
Browns will hire that cut we'll go that
route again but Todd Monken
he had interviews last year he was very
well-liked around the league he has been
buried this year I never understood why
he took this job in the first place it
made no sense for him but at the same
time you have to wonder is he gonna get
his chance and coaching interviews again
yeah you really that is the key you
wonder if that will happen but I think
Matt Campbell's a good direction to go
whoever they have a head coach is gonna
have to make some decisions on free
agency they have for what I would call
key free agents JC Treader at center
Greg Robinson at left tackle damarious
Randall at safety and Joe Schobert
at linebacker JC traders a good player
like I see them trying to keep him
Damaris Randall a very good player when
healthy I could see them maybe keeping
him Joe Schobert
another guy had been banged up a little
bit so I would not be surprised if the
Browns with their 10 draft picks and
their 60 million dollars said we're
gonna try to keep JC Treader otherwise
we're gonna go to the draft we're gonna
go to free agency to try to fill out the
rest of this roster yeah I don't think
this is a team that just goes on some
wild spending spree this offseason now
what's interesting with them is if they
cut Olivier Vernon they save 15 and a
half million dollars that's a pretty
easy savings right there so they can get
some more money if they need it but I
just don't see them going nuts
unless because you got to bring back
shredder he's a good player and this
offensive line can't lose pieces right
now so that's a pretty big contract
right there I think they should can
think they should keep Schobert like you
said Randall and Greg Robinson you know
we'll see what happens there with that I
mean there's no reason to really lose
damarious Randall but once again it's
definitely no lock that he stays so if
the Browns are an interesting spot in
free agency where they don't need to go
nuts because this is a good roster Matt
you don't need to go crazy and
overcompensate for one bad year you can
keep building this through the draft you
just need to nail that coaching hire
yeah I mean that's truly that's where
it's at right now nail the coaching hire
get someone who can develop this team
and again a lot of draft picks here that
they can work with and rebuild this team
so I think that is that's where you look
at and say gosh okay and we're gonna run
through this a mock draft right now the
Browns are expected to pick number seven
overall the biggest need for this team
is at left tackle and we talked about
Andrew Thomas in previous segments I'm
not the biggest believer in his ability
but if the Cleveland Browns are this is
a no-brainer
whether it's Andrew Thomas or Tristan
wharfs or Alex Leatherwood whoever they
end up liking at left tackle and number
seven overall for a team that has pass
rushers in miles garrett and you have
olivier vernon they're pretty good at
defensive tackle I think it's almost
often it's almost left tackle or bust
here for the Cleveland Browns at seven
overall I'm with you I want to answer
Thomas as well and this is why I
actually really like the fit here this
team should get back to its roots of
being a power run team with Nick Chubb
and Andrew Thomas is the type of
offensive lineman that you could
absolutely dominate in the ground game
with he'd be perfect for them I just
think when you look at the fit here if
you want Andrew Thomas to go in the top
ten this is a really nice landing spot
for him Churston and wharfs name will be
in this conversation with a lot of other
offensive linemen but for the four
rounds of drafting I did and I know you
did seven this was kind of a no-brainer
pick yeah absolutely and then second
round pick number forty is where they
would be right now again we talked about
damarious Randall might be a free agent
I think they could still upgrade to the
safety position Xavier McKinney is why I
went with a free safety from Alabama who
has size to play a really either safety
spot and some of this will hinge on who
the defensive coordinator is what
they're doing from a secondary
standpoint you know we've seen Greg
Williams in there running guys 20 yards
deeper safety we've seen a lot of
different variations of this defense so
Xavier McKinney someone I really like it
Alabama I don't think he gets talked
enough about enough excuse me because of
all the talent around him but I needs
the second-best safety in this class and
someone who if they want a center
fielder
I think McKinney is a really natural fit
in that role yeah I went with safety as
well and I love McKinney but the point
of this mock draft is also to show hey
what if that guy is not there so to show
a different look I went with Ashton
Davis from Cal and this is actually one
going to be one of the cooler stories
probably in the draft this year for
davus he goes to Cal he's on the track
team and then a year or two later he
tries out for the football team he walks
on the football team so you have a great
track athlete that turns into a great
defensive back at Cal and I think he
could do a little bit of everything
where Cleveland they've had a lot of
guys injured at corner this year
Davis has played corner before he's
played safety we know what kind of great
athlete he is and he can really really
help the back end of this defense yeah
and then moving into the third round so
we both agree offensive tackle DB moving
into the third round they have two picks
actually I'm going linebacker here
because I don't know if Joe Schobert
will be back Jacob Phillips to LSU
someone I really like I think he has
ability as a three down linebacker now
he is a junior so maybe he doesn't come
out we'll see what happens against LSU
Michael divinity their best linebacker
actually left of the team so Alabama may
be getting a little bit of a blessing in
disguise here with with LSU's best
linebacker leaving the team of Jacob
Phillips has a big role to fill this
weekend this could be a little bit of a
coming out game for him because I do
think he has really good athleticism
good instincts just he hasn't made a ton
of huge plays but I mean Jacob Phillips
he protects well as a starter maybe in
year two of his NFL career yeah he does
and they definitely need a little more
punch in the middle of that defense in
terms of depth because this group has
been murdered by injuries this year but
when you look at you know one area of
need that this was more of a value pick
but it could turn into a need and what
Colin Johnson in the third round here
for whatever reason they don't play
Higgins Callaway is not reliable I don't
know if Jarvis Landry will be on this
team for the long haul because of the
money makes and the production is okay
Odell is not going anywhere everyone
relaxed but to get a little more size in
the red zone with someone like Colin
Johnson in the third round I thought was
a really good value at this point yeah
what Colin when he's on the field he's
exceptional exactly he's been a hurt the
last two years of Texas off and on third
round pick number 89 is where they're
projected be right now I do think the
offensive line needs a little bit of a
boost here we'll see what happens i like
i said i think JC Treader is a guy they
would want to target to bring back
whether he is or isn't
back I still think that the interior of
the line could use some help especially
a right guard so I'm gonna Darryl
Williams from Mississippi State here a
guy who's a bit of a mauler he's to be
very good in the inside run game and I
think he will fit well enough if they
decide to go to like an inside zone
scheme I think he's shown enough ability
to get to the second level which is
gonna be crucial for that so I like
Darryl Williams I'm a believer in his
toughness his physicality I think he
could be a rookie starter honestly on
this offensive line yeah they need to
stack the deck with offensive lineman
that's kind of gonna be a theme here we
talked about it an internal free agency
and then we talked about it with the
first-round pick so then you go with
Williams in the third I looked on the
defensive side of the ball again going
back to DB Myles Bryant he is small but
he is feisty he is nasty and I think he
could be a good slot Corner coming out
of Washington this late in the draft
he's somebody that will be on the field
next year in the NFL that's the kind of
player he is he makes plays in the
backfield it goes back to the way
Washington develops these DBS Budda
Baker was what five eight ninety or
whatever he was it didn't matter he
makes plays and he's still doing it in
the NFL that's how I feel about Myles
Bryan yeah I like Myles Bryant - like
you said I know Jim nag he talked about
him when he was on the show he's tiny
he's tiny but he can play one of my
favorite players the NFL quandary Diggs
tiny but he can play round for the
Browns I'm gonna go corner as well you
just went there I think this is a
position of need for them
Damon Arnett at Ohio State I don't know
if he'll last through the fourth round
because he has played very very well
this year last year not so much but this
year he's an excellent nickel corner
he's probably not gonna be an outside
starter ever in his career but I do
think he's a really good player in the
nickel that he comes in feels a big need
for the Browns just add depth to a
position where didja Ward's been hurt
greedy Williams has been hurt and that
lack of depth has really hurt them this
year yeah it really has and you know
what they've I would say they got
through it they've been losing games but
it's been better at corner than expected
with all of the injuries they've had to
deal with and I think that adding one of
these two young guys we just went
through in our net or Bryant our two
players that should play right away next
year which is good value at this point I
looked at one of the more interesting
chess pieces in this draft grant Calkins
era he's a tight end that's built like a
receiver
kind of plays like a tight end up the
seam I don't know I just know that Baker
Mayfield's can make this guy a weapon in
the middle of the field
they've been banged up at tighten wear
everywhere yeah wherever he plays this
is kind of the right fit for him and I
just think this is a group that can
continue to keep stacking size they get
Colin Johnson early round 3 now calcutta
and round 4 it'd be pretty fun to watch
round 5 i actually went to the defensive
line i feel like this is something that
John Dorsey firmly believes in late in
the draft you want to bolster your line
just draft guys and hope something
sticks I think they could use help at
the defensive tackle position at least
for a rotational player here now talk
about starters like the shoulder
intercept and Larry Okeechobee on
calling anymore but getting depth
Raekwon williamson michigan state six
foot five he's about 285 so he could
play you know one tag three tech if they
ever go to a three-man front he can
bounce out and play over the tackle I
think he has a good potential there
round six
the Browns have two picks and I want
skilled position here this might be more
how I would build a team than how John
will but I'm such a believer late in the
draft I would almost always draft a
receiver a quarterback and maybe a
running back when you have ten picks I
think you could definitely go running
back so what I did here in round six
collage Lipscomb from Vanderbilt who had
a ton of pub as a senior receiver he
actually left the team briefly for some
personal reasons he should be back soon
I like Elijah Lipscomb and Joshua Kelly
at UCLA a physical runner cream hunt is
actually a free agent after this year as
well so whether he's back or not we're
finally gonna see cream hunt play the
Browns could use someone behind Nick
Chubb why not take a flyer in the sixth
round on a player and then around seven
I'm not saying Baker Mayfield is going
anywhere but why not with ten draft
picks draft a quarterback and see what
you have I mean look at where
Jacksonville is now because they took a
chance of Gardner Minshew or look where
Carolina is now because they picked up a
you DFA and Kyle Allen all I would every
year I would add a quarterback that I
like they had some traits so I'm gonna
add Nate Stanley here in round seven if
it doesn't hit oh well it was around
seven but I like like Nate Stanley has
some games and he had some earlier this
year where he looks like a viable
quarterback and he has some games where
you're left wondering what the hell he's
looking at but about the Browns
at least adding more to that room right
now it's Baker is Gary Gilbert is not
enough it's not enough
I still believe Baker's issues can be
fixed but if not you're gonna want some
guys that you can at least have a look
see hey is there anything there let's
kick you know kick the tires on Nate
Stanley a little bit and then with the
final pick I'll go back to the interior
of the offensive line build some depth
here with Shane Lemieux from Oregon
listen I like those picks a lot because
of value I think Kelly is somebody that
will be the forgotten man in this
running back class and will probably go
in the sixth round and can sneak his way
into finding a role on a team I know
Lipscomb probably hasn't lived up to
what we expected coming into this year
but you still bet on the talent and in
terms of backup quarterback we've seen
teams completely neglected coughin New
York Jets and it absolutely burned them
due to one injury stretch that they
simply cannot get through so at that
point of the draft why not
it is draft on draft time we're gonna
kick it off with our guy Patrick
Chamberlain mr. perfect attendance
ranked these potential head coach
openings from most to least desirable
Giants Jets Falcons Redskins
Browns the Falcons have to be the top
because they have a quarterback yet Matt
Ryan yevo Leo Jones they're worse
problems to have than having those great
owner great owner just invested in the
offensive line with two first rounders I
think the Falcons are far and away
number one on this list beautiful
Stadium oh yeah glandt Atlanta's a good
place to be I mean the Falcons is that's
the job in my opinion so I go there you
can win football games right I actually
think the Browns the second-most and I
don't love the owner there but I love
the fan base and I actually I like the
pieces like we just talked about like
sure there's talent there's no shortage
of talent here they're gonna have money
like whatever you think about Baker
Mayfield as how he handles the media or
as a person he was he was a good
quarterback last year he almost won
Rookie of the Year just getting him back
to that I think there's there's enough
talent there to develop I love Nick job
so I think the Browns would be second
great no I don't wear it gets very
shines our Jets
the Redskins are last because ownership
and you would have to do Bruce Allen and
there's no way I'm just not doing it
here's the thing that it comes down to
for me and I hate that I have to go this
way because it makes me sound like a
homer I don't believe in Dave gentlemen
I don't know if Joe Douglas is good but
I also don't know if he's bad no exactly
I don't know if Joe so now the judge now
the flip side is ownership for the
Giants is significantly much better yes
significantly better and now the Daniel
Jones in Samms Arnold is just giving the
football away every week every single
week the both of them are just giving
the football way so we don't know much
about either of those quarterbacks and I
believe they're both the same age so
it's not like it's not like I know
people are like old Daniel Jones is a
rookie but they're both 22 and they both
turned 22 I think in like the same week
so it's a toss-up man like I don't
they're in such bad places both of them
the Giants roster is not very good the
Jets roster is not very good Dave
gentlemen I don't think is very good but
their Giants have good owners Joe
Douglas I think is gonna be okay the
Jets have horrible owners pick your
poison yeah it's it's really tough I
would say that they are there's not a
right answer Giants or Jets does not
like you get a facilities difference
there but it's just personal preference
if you like daniel Jones be dad's sake
one that might actually be the
difference but that's true I would put
the Giants just slightly ahead of the
Jets because of ownership
it's just ownership I know that is such
a great question though we should this
summer rank all 32 teams I like where
you'd want to go work yeah number one
we'll do it all right Peter Cohen I
can't see hashtag Jalen Hertz not going
round one if the hashtag Ravens keep
succeeding more accurate Lamar Jackson
also what's the difference between Henry
rugs and KJ hammer the sides quarterback
and team skill around them
let's break this down yeah the first
ones go for it yeah Jalen hurts as a
runner isn't in the same universe as
Lamar Jackson he's not even in the same
universe it's not even a conversation
and I'm still not convinced he's this
great thrower I'm sorry I am NOT taking
Jalen hurts in the first round and I
openly did like Lamar Jackson in the
first round so if I'm wrong so be it but
not everybody can you can't just find a
Greg Roman everywhere either like I love
Lamar but this system is perfect for him
it I'm so happy it's working out he's
helping the Ravens the Ravens are
helping him I don't think they're the
same player I have a lot my head is
about to explode because there's just so
many different ways I can't like you
know what I mean
yeah I will say so I like the question I
want to I want to be able to that Lamar
Jackson we never saw him run a 40
because he don't want people to say he
was a receiver I think he would have ran
comfortably in the four threes I do not
believe that that Jalen Hurd is anywhere
close to that also don't switch he has
to as natural of emotion as a thrower
now Jalen's motion has gotten a lot
better since leaving Alabama it's looser
but it's nowhere near as loose as
Lamar's it's just not even close so I I
don't see the cop there I think if
anything Jalen Hurd's is like a a more
rigid dak Prescott but I don't know Dax
accuracy I thought eyes on he thought
was better and he definitely wasn't
playing a wide-open scheme like this now
the second part of this question the
difference between Henry rugs and KJ
hammer is 30 pounds yes
it's faster so I guess grabs is for to
hammer hammer is like the Hollywood
Brown build and probably the Miko
Hardman 40 time
yeah handlers listed at 5 9 165 so
whether you believe that or not and rugs
is 6-foot 190 that's a big that's a big
difference rugs is bigger NFL tyree kill
I mean he's thick he's thick but he's
got them it looks like he has long but
he can extend it for the
right rugs no no we just talking about
later so dump him the ball and run like
he could play receiver I want to make
that clear yes so I like Hamlet a lot
he's a little difference she's a little
guy that's okay
way to bring your good questions all
right Jared dub honest do the Colts take
a look at some quarterback so do you
think they roll upper set so I think
they roll Brissette but I think it would
be smart to draft a quarterback late
like we were talking about the Browns
why not you got a ton of picks draft
someone late you know Brian Hoyer is not
you know a backup quarterback to the
future I know they do have Chad Kelly I
think but I'm not a huge believer in
Chad Kelly who it would be a great time
please come on the tailgate tour but not
a huge believer in him as a quarterback
the Colts have eight picks so looking at
I mean they they have 1/7 they have 1/6
and 1/5 I would I would look at one of
those pixs maybe a you know getting a
quarterback do you believe is a
developmental guy I will say this though
the quarterback class we've talked about
it being kind of top-heavy there aren't
those guys late where you're like oh man
give me an 8 Stanley to developer a
Stephen Montez to develop like it's just
there's no one yet where you look at the
the seniors especially and say ok this
guy's gonna fall in the draft but I like
his traits enough to draft him yeah I
think when you look at Jacobi he's
easily done enough to warrant keeping
that job now what you need to know about
Chris Ballard and Ed Dodds is that these
guys are always scouting just always
thinking 2 to 3 years ahead while
everyone's in this one or two year
bubble not everyone but a lot of teams
and I think that's why they'll take
their swings and they'll get a younger
backup on that roster that they want to
see if they could develop the percent is
the presense the guy I mean what more do
you want him to do right now no he's
done he's done everything you can't and
like his stats are good he's plays good
it's just whatever likes him good Peter
I like Oh big fan all right last
question from Mike Daniel and you get to
answer this one first Connor why hasn't
Sam Darnell taken the next step he
showed so much potential late last year
only to look worse now oh there's a lot
of ways we can go about this I think
number one starting the season with mono
didn't do him any favors I mean when you
miss that much time it's not easy even
though he came back and looked
nominal against the Cowboys and then
bottom down after that the offensive
lines miserable the play calling is not
any good
they've lost guys at receiver they lost
the new move right away you know that
obviously hurt them a lot they haven't
had Chris Herndon all year that is his
favorite target I mean the tight end on
the team is Sam Donaldson target Chris
Herndon who should make his season debut
this year and I'm very curious this week
and I'm very curious to see if that
changes anything for how much he relies
on him but Adam GaSe was brought into
developed Arnold and he's regressed
Jeremy Bates cut down his fumbling
issues tightened up his mechanics just
ball security and and he's regressed
back to all those things that were
problems coming out of USC so it's uh
it's the perfect storm I've had a ruin a
22 year old quarterback yeah it feels
like he's not getting any momentum
you know like let talked about on the
Monday show it's like the the mistakes
are just compounding and there isn't a
break where it's like okay you know even
uh what game was that he'll his first
game back where he was like eight of
eight on the first drive and it's like
okay like here we go and then he throws
four picks you know so it's it's so
difficult because he's not not building
on the good place you know because
there's so many mistakes and we could
point to the o-line
put two receivers I don't think it's
it's just on Sam but it's definitely
been a tough year all right that is our
show don't forget the quad on Saturday
morning at 8:00 a.m. to tailgate Oh
kick-off Alabama LSU is gonna be a great
time and our baby boy your de birthday's
actually today when people are listening
to the show we're gonna be celebrating
it this weekend in Alabama are you get
your 28th
I'm turning 28 oh my one more day as
we're recording this of being 27 I know
it's time flown by it's always tough
it's like we want to call out birthdays
on the show and I looked down at the
counter and I was like oh man it's the
fifth but like so there's like when is
the right time so we'll definitely uh
Friday we'll do it have a Connor themed
show but it would be awesome this this
weekend come celebrate Connors birthday
in Tuscaloosa with this it's gonna be a
great time Jacob Hester's gonna be there
Landon Collins Jim naggy Adam Kramer and
the 28 year old Connor Rogers be the
first to give him a birthday hug we'll
talk to you all Friday morning our big
board reveal show from all three hosts
this could be a great time